[Music]
question party is very simple you guys
in the audience are going to ask me and
tara questions and we're going to answer
them yeah it's going to be fun like a
party if you have a question just raise
your hand and we'll call on you stand up
and ask it ask it nice and loud so we
can hear you but don't pull down your
mask we want your questions not your
aerosol droplets okay
let's do this who has a question for me
and tarek i saw you first yes you i
absolutely love you both and i'm so glad
you're here i have a question have you
ever done broadway and would you
consider it
have we ever done broadway and would we
consider it tarek uh
yes i just closed the broadway show uh
freestyle of supreme
thank you
[Music]
it was an amazing time and it whipped my
ass
but uh it was a joy i got to be a guest
on it and then we uh
we tarek and i have known each other
since 2003. so then when we um
uh were taking our bows we took our
about and we looked at each other
[Applause]
cried like two [ __ ] yeah we got out
like we've been booed we've done shows
where we've been booed so
the idea that people enjoy what we do is
still funny to us because we can
remember those
yeah um 27 uh spanish people
in
valencia yeah i think we're like
this is the worst thing i've ever seen
why are they making us do this
you you're very pleasant but never do
comedy
i'm also writing a broadway show called
some like it hot
i gotta very excited
not gonna be in it at all
cause those little children are athletes
throwing each other around and [ __ ] yeah
it's a lot it just it activates
the old lady in me
put her down
why are you doing this
okay that's all the time we have for
question party this was great should we
do it again sometimes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you